sebastian zeigt wie großkonzerne billig
fertig paddys für vegane bürger
herstellen
nestlé unilever oder aldi wollen mit
veganen geld machen und kleist eine
erstaunliche zutaten aus der ganzen welt
zusammen ist das noch gut für die umwelt
diese natürlichen verpackungen man denkt
man läuft in den garten eden und man
bekommt aus pflanzlichen produkten das
original was man kennt was kräftig nach
dem fleisch schmeckt aber die romantik
ist schnell vorbei wenn man auf die
rückseite schaut
sebastian hat die zutaten für den
veggieburger mitgebracht von frischem
gemüse keine spur
[Musik]
die pflanzliche basis des bürgers ist
trocken und sieht erstaunlich fleischig
aus
wird giulia und erbsen protein gemacht
gehört auch so ein dünner fetzen sein
diese kleinen schnipsel sorgen dafür
dass es genauso schön widerstand gibt
wie beim echten rindfleisch burger
deswegen muss auch dieses soja texte rat
geholfen werden soja textur rat ist eine
hoch verarbeitete zutat sojabohnen
werden dafür zerkleinert und in
maschinen so lange bearbeitet bis sie
die gewünschte fleisch ähnliche
konsistenz bekommen
für die basis des fleischfreien burgers
ist noch eine weitere ungewöhnliche
zutat notwendig
sie müssen auch die sägespäne als sind
komplette erbsen fasern herbstes ganz
reich an eiweiß deswegen werden sie
gerne in pflanzliche produkte
eingearbeitet
als einen ähnlichen bis erzeugt wie
fleisch geschmack und farbe liefern
aromen und gewürze in pulverform wasser
und öl sorgen für die saftigkeit das
ergebnis ein router fleisch ähnlicher
partie der muss zum ersten test diesem
breit zu drehen was sie aber nicht
wirklich viel versprechende aus das
ergebnis mangelhaft der wasseranteil ist
hoch und die trockenen komponenten
können sich nicht mit der flüssigkeit
verbinden
deshalb brauchen die fleischlosen burger
fast immer einen ganz speziellen
zusatzstoff methyl zellulose oder 461
[Musik]
der basiert auf natürlich vorkommenden
pflanzenfasern die synthetisch unter
vakuum behandelt werden mittel zellulose
hält im kleister auch tapeten an der
wand
sebastian lege gibt mit zellulose zu
seiner bürger masse hinzu
und schon klappte formen deutlich besser
blieb der partie nun auch in der pfanne
zusammen
[Musik]
und jetzt hat es gehalten
so einfach geht das richtig dosiert ist
mit zellulose gesundheitlich nicht
problematisch ob man sowas in seinem
essen haben möchte ist eine andere frage
in fleischersatz bürgern aus dem
supermarkt finden sich einige
zusatzstoffe 461 wird dabei besonders
oft eingesetzt kein fleisch ersatz
burger aus dem supermarkt kommt ohne den
kleber methyl zellulose aus 1 fällt
unangenehm auf ein großteil der produkte
ist dem viel zu viel plastik eingepackt
sind sie wirklich so umweltschonend
um das herauszufinden reisen wir ins
tschechische krupka rund 50 kilometer
südlich von dresden
hier produziert nestlé für seine marke
garden gourmet den incredible burger die
produktion läuft auf hochtouren denn der
absatz des veganen produkt steigt stetig
der hersteller verrät die gründe dafür
die motivatoren für die verbraucher
warum sie das jetzt gerade in letzter
zeit stark gekauft haben weil der
klimaschutz natürlich ein ganz großer
aspekt so recht der veggie burger wird
aus vielen inhaltsstoffen hergestellt
unter anderem aus soja und auch für den
garten gumberger hat das so ja eine
lange reise hinter sich
50 prozent kommen aus den usa die andere
hälfte immerhin aus europa genauer aus
serbien
doch nicht nur die zutaten sorgen für
co2 ausstoß der große run auf die burger
hat nestlé überrascht und auch das sorgt
für umweltprobleme
denn verpackungsmaschinen fehlen bislang
deshalb werden die pettys nicht vor ort
in tschechien verpackt wo aber dann
wir werden wenn in england abgepackt
weil dort die erwartung dass der größte
markt ist und plus hat das dort war
jemand die mengen handeln konnte und
auch in der qualität hat dass das
managen konnte machen konnte kein
klimafreundliches prinzip von der
tschechischen republik werden die bürger
per dies nach großbritannien verfrachtet
dort werden sie eingepackt und dann
wieder zurück in deutsche supermärkte
verschiebt
[Musik]
wir wollen wissen welche auswirkungen
das auf die co2 bilanz hat und lassen
auch die gesamtbilanz des veggie burger
für diesen film berechnen
wer schneidet besser ab ein hamburger
aus rindfleisch von einem lokalen co2
sensible betrieb oder ein lemberger der
quer durch europa transportiert wird
das ergebnis überrascht 100 gramm veggie
burger verursachen 320 gramm co2 beim
fleisch hamburger sind es 1940 gramm
das sind fünfmal mehr
die futtermengen die bei der
rindfleischproduktion verbraucht werden
sind schlicht zu groß
vegetarische produkte haben immer eine
bessere bilanz auch wenn sie aufwendig
hergestellt wurden so kann man
grundsätzlich sagen dass sie diese
produkte besser abschneiden
die bürger sind demnach
umweltfreundlicher was die co2 bilanz
bei der herstellung angeht
wollt ihr pettys selber machen dann
klickt auf nelsons rezept für leckere
vegane bürger und wenn ihr noch mehr
über ihr essen wissen wollt dann
abonniert zdf besser esser und schaut
die nächsten zwei clips